how do you handle when someone's
insulting you and and actually again
there's this difference between ribbing
and fun and actual insults now if
someone's ribbing me for fun if they're
giving me a hard time about something
I'm totally cool I'll laugh I'll you
know I'll throw some ribbing back at
them I I realize that I have all kinds
of attributes that are real easy to make
fun of and I have I'm totally good with
it right like so I'm fine
I think that's good
you know and I think you know I mean I
hassle you all the time again not
harassment to the tune of like I'm
actually trying to impose my you know uh
ego and personality on you and me I
don't do that right
and you are super chill and laughed at
it and you know you do you you have a
good way of taking whatever ribbing
comes your way and utilizing it to carry
on and you know make a statement about
it too so so that's cool